over the years I know they as part of
your job like mine I talked to a lot of
famous people and I think you're very
good at sort of becoming friendly with
them and me less so I've got a couple of
friends here and there but you've got
all these famous friends and I'm always
thinking like oh is that something that
you set out did you know that you were
just good at making friends cuz I was
never good at it I was never good at
just easily making friends especially
with other famous people I always
assumed they don't want to talk to me
that's interesting I mean I know I mean
from listening to your podcast I didn't
realize that you had so few friends I
would have thought that now wait that's
not what I say no it's like it was just
yes
okay i yeah i do get curious when i see
other people who are like yourself who
are very good at like you meet someone
and I think I get a little
self-conscious
you never self-conscious about that like
you'll meet like a Jennifer Aniston or
something and then say hey let's go
let's go get us some sloppy joes yeah
but I'm a real social person like I like
to be around people all the time I think
you're a little bit more introverted and
I'm a little bit more extroverted you
know right no I I try really really hard
I think that's what they're picking up
on is I'm like come on you want to get a
sloppy joe Jennifer Aniston I think they
find that creepy yeah I feel I felt for
many years that it was part of the
requirement the job requirement to be
friends with so many people because you
have to keep having them back on the
show and there's some you know I just
felt like it was part of my job Wow okay
and it was natural like to do that
because I